[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je sais par où il est passé sylvain mais
qu'est ce que tu fais
ça va être ça va ça va être alors gardez
brad brad est
on est on est vraiment en retard 2
en coop ou encore
incertain
donc j'ai acheté des colonnes pour ma
salle de bain sur un site de vente de
meubles et elles sont là voilà et je
vais les montées maintenant pas ce qui
s'est passé a dû me coûter 100 balles
les deux colonnes et ils m'ont proposé
livraison et montage à domicile je crois
que le montage c'était
4970 jeu d'une heure je vais faire c'est
bon je vais le faire voilà donc il est
et 9h08
honnêtement je pense que d'ici une heure
c'est fini les colonnes surmontées
on avait dire
on avait dit une heure c'est à peu près
ça quand il est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
point de côté vous en avez sûrement eu
en courant mais c'est quoi ce point de
côté je vous dise à un point de côté ce
produit en généralement quand on fait un
effort surtout quand on court et qu'on
respire mal le point de côté il est dû à
quoi à une contracture d'un muscle très
important qui s'appelle le diaphragme
qui est un muscle qui sépare le thorax
donc poumons et coeur du bas du corps
c'est-à-dire tout ce qui est dans le
ventre tout ce qui est dans l'abdomen se
muscle est très important parce que
c'est lui qui se contracte et qui se
détend quand vous respirez si on respire
mal il va y avoir une contracture un
endroit précis de ceux de ce diaphragme
et c'est cette contracture que l'on
ressent comme une douleur comme un point
de côté tous ceux qui en on sait ce
qu'il faut faire en général il faut
arrêter ou bien ralentir le rythme
soufflez expiré expiré expiré expiré
expiré à fond et puis respirer
normalement et après une fois qu'il a
disparu pas vous reprenez votre course
mais en respirant le plus régulièrement
possible